[Musique]
et pour la saint valentin après le
restaurant c'est aussi l'occasion
d'aller voir un spectacle bonfort
mélanie poker ou soir à magny les
hameaux on joue la carte du sexy et du
glamour la maison de l'environnement
laisse sa scène à une effeuilleuse eh
oui valentina delplace vous entraîne
dans un cabaret burlesque de
l'effeuillage un divertissement qui met
le cabaret coquin et comédies légères
alors lancé dans les cabarets parisiens
à la fin du 19e siècle style s'est
exportée aux états unis pour donner les
fameuses pin up pour ce jeudi quête en
février le burlesque club décortique les
façades du mouvement un petit extra
[Musique]
oui
je ne peux pas je
[Musique]
le mans mais aussi lumeau et oui elles
sont cinq sur scène cinq artistes
effeuilleuses cannelle doubleclick
mamzelle plus n'tima rade nude et
rosabelle c'est la vie et sucre d'orge l
art elle alterne des numéros poétiques
drôles et parfois totalement kitsch et
complètement assumé la place est laissée
aux rétro à l'humour au comique et la
soirée continuera après le spectacle
puisque un buffet spécial saint valentin
concocté par les amis de l'estaminet est
prévue merci mélanie dans un instant on
vous retrouve aux manettes du 7-8
culture